you can help flm chocolate celebrate a
special anniversary
by participating in a new limited time
tasting
at their flagship store we've got rocky
theos with more on
chocolate and champagne we are still
here at ethelens enjoying our
chocolate and mimosa tasting a special
event they're doing through may for
spring and of course for their 40th
anniversary
lisa i can't believe i called this work
i can't believe you called but you do
work
exactly it's a lot of fun and what
better way to kick off our 40th right
yes so let's talk to tammy joe our
chocolates here we're going to choose
another chocolate
yes and pair it with our mimosa so which
one did you want to try this time
i'm going with this guy oh okay that's a
perfect one that one is our vanilla
truffle so go ahead and take a look at
that one smell your chocolate
and then go ahead and take a bite and
what flavors are you noticing oh my
goodness well the vanilla is just so
potent that's strong and it's delicious
taste a little honey too
absolutely so these are the other flavor
notes that you might notice in your
piece it goes into dairy it goes into
sweet aromatics with a little bit of
that honey
and of course creamy rich buttery
ganache
and go ahead and try your mimosa now and
see how the flavors mix together and
dance
perfect so this is our white peach
prosecco and fruit puree and that's why
it blends so well with the vanilla
that is so cool and obviously you guys
have professionally paired these
there's a reason why so you guys have to
come down here and try them
um but i just want to end this segment
on
celebrating at the limbs because you
guys have been here for 40 years since
1981
and i have a special surprise for you
lisa oh great i'm going to bring in our
couple here that i met
earlier in the cactus gardens come on in
come on in
put my mask on now you guys told me you
were taking photos in the cactus garden
and you said
and i asked you was this your first time
here and you said no we've been here
since
it opened in back in 1981 40 years ago
yes we have
we were out here within a day or two of
its opening i'm not sure it was opening
day
we have come out consistently ever since
we no longer live here but
it's the thing we do with our grandkids
oh that's so special how do you do that
and what was it like back then
this was in the middle of nowhere it was
a long drive and it was not very large
but the chocolate was delicious and you
could go through and watch them make the
chocolate
so it's it's it's grown so much
and for years this has been our favorite
chocolate
now the new one is even better like the
the type of truffle you taste
the one i just had yes that's the only
one i've ever found that's better than
the old at the lamb so that says a lot
that says a lot it's a great testimonial
we need to get you guys at a tasting so
lisa just let everybody know at home how
they can come and do this as well
absolutely it's super easy just go to
flm.com and you can book a tasting on
the weekends now through may
perfect you have you have video our zoom
tastings now too don't you
she's definitely been coming here for 40
years i love that i will send it back to
you guys celebrate at the limbs just a
gem in our community